hi I'm Jody and I'm Sarah and we live
going down a real rabbit hole fighting
out the stories behind weird stuff we
see on the internet I saw something
interesting on the internet the other
day of course he did I so scrolling
Twitter a late at night and I saw what
looked like a really realistic baby doll
of the Navi from Avatar directed by
James Cameron if you're not familiar
with it I don't know why you wouldn't be
get familiar I feel like when I saw that
Betar baby I should have been like of
course that's a thing that exists on the
Internet it feels like it's late for
avatar baby who is the market for this
doll why does it exist okay what is it
real it's um I'm not sure how I feel
about it
those pills look real though I do there
are so many questions
did somebody paint these babies are you
serious oh it's a doll I thought people
painted their babies that is such an
impressive job that someone has done but
also I'm really happy it's not babies
it's pretty creepy but I also kind of
want one I don't want it to touch me but
he's kind of cute well we did some
research and the story behind these
dolls is actually really surprising
these are one of a variety of
hyper-realistic dolls called reborns the
original reborns are designed to look
like real human babies and not Navi
there's a huge online community for
these dolls and for the people who own
them and they aren't cheap this isn't
your average doll the price of a reborn
can range anywhere from two hundred to
three thousand dollars and up with the
most high-quality dolls starting around
a thousand dollars I guess it makes
sense looking at them it's not the same
kind of doll that you're buying for your
kid they look like almost like
high-quality movie props you just have
to wonder what is it about them that are
making people spend thousands of dollars
on these dolls and they're like sold out
there's a high demand for these dolls
it's really easy to scoff at such a high
price for what most people would assume
is just a fancy toy but these dolls
serve a very real purpose for many
people they're a tool for working
trauma and loss what's special about
these dolls is that they are extremely
realistic in appearance
they even weigh the same as a real baby
many people believe it is soothing to
hold or take care of a baby and these
dolls can provide that comfort the dolls
have been known to help people who
suffer from dementia Alzheimer's and
depression
some people may own them as a way to
remember a child they have lost others
own them as a way to compensate for not
being able to have children there are a
variety of reasons someone may own a
reborn but most of them are deeply
sentimental and meaningful to their
owner I think that's something that was
really surprising for us because you see
an avatar baby and honester and you're
like I'm gonna make fun of this a lot of
people talk to you and then you kind of
feel like a jerk when you realize
there's a deeper story there I think
like when you see something that you
don't understand your first instinct is
to be like well I wouldn't buy that so
it's dumb or like I don't understand
that so I'm gonna make fun of it I was
really surprised to learn that like
these provide a real purpose they can be
really therapeutic for people I think it
also makes a lot of sense because people
instinctually want to care and nurture
something how did we get from the
realistic human baby dolls to the Navi
dolls in the world one of the more
popular ones was made by a company
called baby clown and according to their
website it's actually licensed by 20th
Century Fox which i guess cuz it's on
the internet and on their website like
it really does look official and I'm
willing to believe it but I'm very
surprised 20th Century Fox was like love
that stamp why not give me a cut of
those babies I can't believe that they
are officially licensed I also can't
believe I said give me a cut of those
babies I hate that phrase but Navi
babies are not the only pop culture
themed dolls on the market we did some
googling as you do and found there are a
ton of these pop culture and fantastical
reborns there are werewolves dragons
aliens Shrek Freddy Krueger
you can even get custom baby dolls made
to look like your favorite character if
you can dream it you can doll it if you
can dream it you can doll it if you
could have any pop culture themed baby
or monster themed baby what would it be
all I know is that I absolutely don't
want the Pennywise baby because that
would haunt all the dreams artistically
beautiful impressive stunning amorous
terrifies me so there's a lot of dolls
out there there's a lot more than just
the avatar doll I still have a lot of
questions about them well I don't have
the answers but I found someone who does
oh did you quickly for me just state
your name and who you are okay hi I'm
azita Gonzalez of cosmic encounters
nursery and I make fantasy reborn dolls
can you tell me about how you got
started doing that I used to have an
eBay store so I was always on eBay and
I've always had a love for dolls I came
across a reborn doll for the first time
I was like what is this it looks so real
I got started with aliens of all things
I came across this vintage alien doll
and I thought you know that might look
cute as a baby and people actually liked
it so this is a this is a fully painted
fantasy baby doll how long did that doll
take you to make it's usually more like
a four to ten week length of time to
complete at all Wow what do you think it
is that people love about these dolls
sometimes people want a specific doll to
take to a convention some people use
them for cosplay a lot of times the
people that want the more human doll
they're wanting it for more of the
therapeutic reasons but I also see that
with the fantasy dolls really yes I
think there's this innate human nature
to find a baby a door of all like you
want to nurture it what do you think is
something about reborn dolls or the
reborn
unity the people don't know that you
wish they did there's a lot of judgment
that these people are subjected to each
individual has their own story
some people even you know this helps
them to cope with the loss of a child
I've had people take these into the
hospital with them when they're getting
chemotherapy just as you can receive a
therapeutic response from you know
petting an animal it's the same thing
with holding one of these dolls you know
just be kind it seems like the reason
people buy them it really depends and
there's a lot of different reasons why
people do but at the end of the day they
seem to make people happy I don't think
it's for me but that kind of doesn't
matter if your thing makes you happy you
should not be ashamed of it
you know life is short the earth is
terrible that's where we as people have
bigger fish to fry seems like you can
make a lot of money making them let's
brainstorm if you open a store what it
would be called Sarah slimy baby why
slimy just cuz they're alliteration yeah
what else could be several babies Sarah
Sarah we only carry several babies at a
time but get your checkbooks ready cuz
they're come